[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le corps du moins nous a toujours fait
ce n'est de l'homme de cro magnon
jusqu'à aujourd'hui en passant par
toutes les civilisations anciennes
le premier traité de notre vie nous
vient des égyptiens qui mille cinq cents
ans avant jésus-christ avait déjà
identifié de nombreux points
névralgiques du corps incluant une
description du cerveau incroyable
tout ça a été décrit dans un document le
fameux papyrus démoniste lutte un
collectionneur américain qui en avait
fait la question et qu'il a fait
analyser et des galeries il faut aussi
parler du grec
hippocrate dont les traités et les
écrits d'anne de 400 ans avant
jésus-christ il pas grave revers est
considéré comme le père de la médecine
moderne puis qu'il est le premier à
proposer des traitements pour des
problèmes reliés aux gangs par la suite
vitruve 1 h théâtre romain s'est lui
aussi intéressé aux comme il était
fasciné par le fonctionnement infiniment
complexe du comme le célèbre dessin de
leonardo domenici l'homme de vitruve met
en images les proportions rejette lynch
corps humain tel que mesuré par vitreux
exercice est maintenant celle
passionnant et toute cette fascination
pour le corps humain continue encore
aujourd'hui se pendre dans sa plus
simple expression
l'homme au bout sapiens
est un super assemblage de trilliards de
milliards de molécules majoritairement
des molécules d'eau bien sûr mais aussi
des minéraux des lipides et glucides des
hormones des acides aminés des protéines
évidemment le dr et beaucoup d'autres
encore
c'est ce qu'on appelle les molécules de
leiris avec des millions d'années
d'évolution des atomes se sont associés
entre eux pour former ces molécules de
la vie par la suite les molécules se
sont associés entre elles pour former
les premières cellules vivent les
cellules brisement agnès eux mais qu'ils
avaient la possibilité de se reproduire
et d'évoluer avec l'évolution des
molécules se sont associés ensemble pour
former des cellules beaucoup plus
spécialisée et ses cellules spécialisées
se sont associés entre elles pour former
des êtres vivants beaucoup plus complexe
jusqu'au souvent mains de la conquête et
moléculaire les humains l'humain est
donc un super assemblage de triage de
milliards de molécules maintenant 100
dans une hiérarchie précise par des
triades 2 milliards d'intérêts que cela
mais mieux encore le corps humain enfin
test réacteurs chimiques et à tout
instant de notre vie des millions
quelquefois des milliards de réactions
chimiques ont lieu dans l'auto et ses
réactions chimiques menus permettent de
digérer la nourriture de nous fournir
l'énergie nécessaire pour nous déplacer
de nous défendre contre les envahisseurs
de pincer bref de vivre et de survie
grâce mais mieux encore ce fabuleux
réacteur chimique est toujours à l'
équilibre
rien ne se perd rien ne se crée tout se
transforme
audi a3 de la voisine 1789
le corps humain est en équilibre mais un
équilibre très fragile
un équilibre qui perturbé par tout ce
que l'on fait tout ce que l'on voit tout
ce que l'on sort tout ce que l'on
ressent manger 10 mai 13 ips et boit de
l'alcool se donne un coup de marteau sur
le pousse à regarder un film d'horreur
tout sa voix altérée les kilims
chimiques de notre corps est en réponse
à des stimuli notre cave a produit une
myriam substances chimiques qui vont
nous permettre de faire face à ces
événements
des molécules sont capables de
neutraliser l'acidité des gardes et
l'alcool
diminuer la douleur de tous détruits
l'adrénaline
en d'autres mots de nous adapter nous
les humains à toutes ces suez
et pour illustrer ce concept quoi de
mieux que l'amour en effet vous avez
vous déjà posé la question pourquoi vous
aviez des papillons dans l'estomac des
chaleurs une extension un contrôle juste
à la vue de quelqu'un qui vous attirait
pourquoi ressenti un sentiment de
bonheur et de confort en voyant
quelqu'un qui m'était très cher et ce
même après tant d'années c'est que l'âme
ou d'impuissance stimulus qui va altérer
les kilims chimiques de notre cas et
grâce à les appliquer d'imagerie les
siens se fait coter capables d'étudier
la chimie du corps mais en amour et ils
ont identifié les substances chimiques
responsables
l'amour passionnel du désir amoureux de
la peine d'amour etc
l'amour c'est chimiques telles pratiques
le coup de foudre vous savez le coup de
foudre le cas de personnes sera content
que le quart se met à battre est grave
et qu'on des paquets de mer qu'on fait
des choses pour tout à fait cohérent
puisque je devais de côte-chaude penser
que ça arrive seulement dans les films
de tromper le coup de foudre existe
vraiment il provoque un moody's mais des
comportements très bizarre parfois
presque élastique
les scientifiques se sont penchés sur ce
sujet et ne serez pas surpris
d'apprendre que ce qu'ils ont trouvé
c'est que tout se joue au cerveau
lorsque vous voyez votre coup de foudre
dans votre cerveau vous avez une
activité chimique des résidences des
maudits culture ou m6 puis s'en vont
être traduites et celle simon prendre le
contrôle total de votre corps bon wagon
le coup de foudre s'exercer et les
sciences fait qu inutiles cerveau des
personnes qu'ils ressentaient un amour
passionnel un terme moins romancée mais
plus scientifique pour dire coup de
foudre
est ce qu'ils ont trouvé fascinant le
coup de foudre à se repérer dans une
toute petite région d'un cerveau en
plein coeur de celui ci donc on appelle
le noyau caudé et tout est contrôlé par
quatre
cette substance chimique car petit
substances dont de très très gros effets
sonores
la première c'est l'infini de la mine
une véritable drogue la dignité la mine
est une en vitamines naturelles et
lorsqu'elle est produite dans notre
cerveau elle procure un sentiment de
confort et de bien-être
il n'est guère lui on est seul au monde
la tête
été tourné et l'expression consacrée on
est sur un nuage
voilà c'est le gros de cette drogue
naturelle là finissent l'année
l'adrénaline par la dopamine elle elle
va nous procurer une étude d'extension
car dans notre cerveau on a des
milliards de bep comptabilité ce qu'on
appelle durant il le courant passe à
travers du neurone par des
neurotransmetteurs particulièrement
l'adoubé mines
lorsqu'on voit notre coup de foudre on
va avoir des tonnes de six mois on va
voir des temps de douter mais libéré
dans notre cerveau celles ci vont
littéralement court circuiter notre
réseau neurones et neutre notre système
nerveux voire s'embellit les
conséquences de ce 100 m c'était la
première c'est que ça stimule l'humeur
et l'entousiasme on y touche joyeux
joyeuse on est tout le temps souvent on
sait pas pourquoi mais on est tout le
temps parce qu'on est sous les fûts et
l'effet de la dopamine est
malheureusement certaines personnes ont
un excès de dopamine
ce qui fait que ça ne me met dans un
état de surexcitation je suis sûr que
vous savez ce que je dis surtout pour
vous mais si vous connaissez sur mille
temps sûrement quelques à qui c'est
arrivé
la prochaine très intéressant vous savez
que mon comportement caractéristique des
gens cela pris d'un coup de folie d'âge
il est très bizarre
vous savez l'expression c'est je ne sais
pas ce qui m'a pris je n'étais pas dans
mon état normal et bien situer cette
substance qu'on appelle la
norépinéphrine la norépinéphrine c'est
une molécule qui provoque un sentiment
du fond
elle va interférer avec nos processus
décisionnel elle va faire qu'on est
moins rationnel et quelquefois
irrationnelle et elle va nous faire
faire toutes sortes de choses qu'on ne
ferait pas dans un état normal
ces levées de la norépinéphrine et la
dernière vous la connaissez bien
l'adrénaline la molécule de l'urgence
l'adrénaline a plusieurs effets
biologiques jeunes auteurs elle nous
rend plus alerte elle fait augmenter
notre température corporelle
mais surtout elle fait augmenter le
rythme cardiaque
ce qui fait que le coeur bat la chamade
meilleur un nom très ferme biologique
quand on parle beaucoup moins au sujet
de l'adrénaline c'est qu'elle permet
d'augmenter la pression artérielle
ce qu'il veut dire que on devient beau
comme une tomate et voici
nous avons tous les éléments scouts
foule on est rouge comme une tomate le
coeur du débat
on a des chaleurs on est on rit tout le
temps aucune raison on fait des choses
irrationnelles
le coup de foudre c'est chimique on ne
peut pas empêcher un coup de feu mais on
a des coups de feu des répétitions dans
notre vie on a des coups de coude à
n'importe quel âge on était coup de
foudre dans n'importe quelle
circonstance
mais si beau si intense soit le coup de
foudre
toutes les aides une science des le
confirme le coup de foudre
ça ne dure pas
en effet au fameux ce qu'on progresse
dans une relation amoureuse
la concentration des moluques une du
coup de foudre ce matin diminuer à
partir de 18 mois pour disparaître
complètement
après quelques années mais n'ayez
crainte car la chimie vient au secours
des amoureux et l'amour passionnel peut
se transformer dans un amour qui veut
qu'on appelle durable mais qui peut
résister toute la vie et une seule
molécule est responsable de ce phénomène
incroyable
c'est le site au film le scénario yen à
moi avec les molécules du coup de foudre
le stationner d'une hormone on appelle
leur nom de l'attachement elle va
prendre la relève des molécules du coup
de foudre à un puzzle aux jeux ste cène
et d'un relaxant musculaire
alors lorsque deux coups de foudre qui
ne sont plus coup de foudre se
rencontrent dans l'accord le staff doit
être produit et vous relaxer leurs muses
ont diminué leurs tensions et provoqué
le sentiment de confort et de bien-être
durable
recherché pour de nombreuses années et
c'est ça qui va transformer de l'amour
passionnel dans un amour oral le coup de
foudre c'est chimique mais ça ne veut
pas mais le système prend la relève pour
un amour de la vie l'amour c'est celle
là vous êtes impuissant stimulus qui
vont altérer l'équilibré chimique de
notre corps ce sont d'énormes quantités
de recherche scientifique de points qui
ont permis cette compréhension d'un
finalement pourtant omniprésent dans la
vie
une superbe illustration de l'importance
de la recherche scientifique
fondamentale pour comprendre la
physiologie humaine car seuls y compris
un son du cor mais au niveau moléculaire
vont nous permettre de développer des
thérapies plus efficaces pour traiter
les maux qui nous afflige nous les zooms
et particulièrement ceux qui touche le
cerveau ou une il ya des processus
biologiques nous échappe pas encore à
notre compréhension et avec des
trilliards de milliards de molécules
maintenu un sens dans un et qu'il est
parfait par des trilliards de milliards
d'interaction on peut dire sans crainte
que l'homme homo sapiens est un faible
le réacteur chimique toujours rempli de
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de secrets
merci
[Applaudissements]